Five Nights at Freddy's won't be the
first time that Josh Hutcherson is
playing someone who works long hours
somewhere sketchy from 2017 to 2020 he
played the main character of Josh on the
Hulu comedy series future man Josh is a
janitor who beats an unbeatable video
game and is then joined by The Game's
characters in a quest to truly change
the future Hutcherson is also of course
well known for his time as Peta malar in
The Hunger Games franchise Hutcherson's
capacity for conveying heartache comedy
and duplicity makes his casting as Mike
Schmidt and FNAF particularly exciting
even in the trailers it's clear that
he'll make viewers feel sympathetic to
his flight Hutcherson is also quite
capable of playing to villainous and
surprising strengths like when he's
Charming the blue hair off of Stanley
tui's Caesar flickerman in The Hunger
Games or when he's making Katniss
everine question whether his love for
her is real or all just a show for his
own Survival he's sure to bring similar
nail-biting acting abilities to Five
Nights at Freddy's